in so many words
it's ridiculous to think that somebody
like el
chapo i think he only got life plus 30
years
he got half the sentence ross got half
percent and your son got
double life double life plus 40 years
it's it's it's ridiculous it's such a
use of government power it's shocking
it's it's it is it puts us all in danger
if some judge
and by the way it was her fifth life
sentence that year it was only may
you know she's quite free with the life
sentences this woman although she's
retired now
thankfully for justice you know she
shouldn't be
she you know i was told by a very high
powered lawyer in new york she had no
business being on the bench
but anyway she was and um but yeah
el chapo half the sentence um
noriega noriega got 20 years
you know and there's a we have a whole
list of kingpins on our site
that have a fraction of the sentence
ross does ross who has no
record of violence no um
history in his life of violence nothing
you know he said he's a geek an
idealistic geek who had who
you know i'm not saying hey not a good
idea
mistake he admits it he regrets it
but double life plus 40 years for that
is there any chance that he'll that he
could be
pardoned i'm hopeful you know there's
always a chance
i'm hopeful um i've heard stuff like
that with like edward snowden that there
was a chance of him possibly getting
pardoned
there's it could be hopeful for him too
i mean president trump has
indicated and shown that he
he is very open to clemency for people
he is
he has given pardons and commutations to
people during his term
his four years and he also pushed for
the first step act
against the will of a lot of his party
to
which improved thousands of well brought
thousands of people out of prison who
are serving these horrible sentences
that are way
past what they should be serving and
destroying so many families
so i think you know president trump
could see i i hope he can see
that um this sentence is is actually a
terrible precedent
that not only hurts ross but can hurt
others because it sets this press
now a precedent is set for non-violent
first-time offender no criminal record
whatsoever
no um nothing about harming anyone
inflicting bodily injury or any of that
getting double life plus 40 years
this is unheard of but i
i think that i can tell you my theory on
it
um i think that uh he
threatened some very powerful people
with the idea of bitcoin
bitcoin was very new and unknown and i
think that
having this currency that was out of the
control
of the financial powers um i think that
was a real
issue and i think that they needed to
make an example
and one of the reasons i think so is
that a couple of years ago the intercept
uh revealed through snowden
that the nsa was urgently tracking
bitcoin users
and trying to track them down a few
months before the silk road was taken
down
they were concerned about bitcoin they
were concerned about this thing
and i think that ross because and one of
i wasn't sure about it you know i
thought well maybe it's the drugs maybe
it's this that
even though he was never accused of
actually selling drugs
um because but then i saw that the
biggest drug seller on the site
got 10 years he has the same offense
level as ross
so obviously they're not that concerned
about the drugs
you know um and it goes down from there
everybody involved in the case got
way less time and the guy who was
running silk road 2
which was a copycat site only was bigger
according to the government
uh he got no time he's out he he just
i don't know how he got out but he did
you know because they were saying we
caught him and all that and suddenly
he went away so his name is blake
benthal
b-e-n-t-h-a-l-l and um
so nobody i i was like whatever happened
to that guy and i we went on the
the prison website and they tell you
where different inmates are
and his had released he was released
after 14 13 14 days after he was
arrested
and he was running a bigger site copycat
the government called identical and so
this is wrong you know you don't give
one sentence to
for similar crimes you that's this is
ridiculous no sentence versus
double lifeless 40. you know
makes no sense what what do you think it
was
what do you think the the true
if there could possibly be any logical
explanation for it
even if it's buried in like
the muck of prosecutors and the politics
of the whole thing
what do you think the reason was they
put
some or they went to the extent to try
to
cover up things and and lie about things
to try to slam him with this insane
sentence
like obviously they wanted to make an
example of him right
but what do you think do you think there
was like a a deeper
underlying uh
incentive for them to do this besides
the
i mean i don't think it's personal or
anything i think you know
they wanted a trophy they do they and
you can see in our um
they're our thing on the um we have a
video it's also a podcast it's also
written
it's all footnoted it's based on the
public record they knew
they knew that um he in fact the lead
investigator in the case
never thought it was ross never thought
ross was uh
the dread pirate roberts now um
i and it's pretty well established and
he even said at trial i heard him with
my own ears
that there were many people that were
running that site it wasn't just ross
but according to the you know the
old-fashioned thing they need
a a perpetrator they need a perpetrator
and
i you know i think ross was set up
i think you know he took the fall for
this but
it's pretty well established he was not
the only one
and um but they you know it's like
putting a the head on the
pika in in medieval castle you know
when you know if you do what they did
you're going to end up with your head on
a pike
right that's what they were attempting i
think with this and the
actually the prosecutors didn't even ask
for double life that judge gave it to
him
they wanted you know they wanted a hefty
sentence but they never
publicly at least said double life or
even life
so she just you know decided he deserved
to die
in a cage literally and um no redemption
no chance you know he's 29 when this
happened
and no that young never
violent and he doesn't get a chance to
redeem himself
you know uh it's it's not american it's
just it's like something you'd have in a
tyrannical state not in america
well i think the i think america has uh
the most
prisoners per capita than any country
that's correct
that's correct it's terrible it's an
outrage and it's been since
[Laughter]
you